hello can I explain relativity to you
okay let's try it so there's what's true
and there's what's real
things that are true exist in a model
they're perfect they're sort of like
those boxes that you have a
three-dimensional coordinate system
these are three dimensions so it's like
the steel rods stick into all parts of
the universe but actually that doesn't
make any sense at all because well we're
movin actually all the time a long time
ago Newton thought that we weren't
moving he thought that everything was
perfect there was this thing called
space so when I walk through I know that
I'm moving through space there's this
thing and it's just there but I'm the
only thing moving but then that's
changes when maybe this thing called
technology happens and we have the train
let's give it two cars for now the train
think about being in motion on the train
think about falling asleep on the train
so if you fall asleep on the train and
you can't really hear the sound you
close your eyes and you wake up and
you're on the train and you look out the
window and you're passing another train
do you know if you're moving or do you
know if that trains moving if you're not
accelerating can't actually feel the
motion so who's moving and actually
there's no absolute still and there's no
absolute motion if I start spinning here
is the room spinning room I spinning
because i think the room spinning and i
think i'm standing still I don't know
it's all relative
you